[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday April 6th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Sam Altman is the 37 year old co-founder
of openai the startup behind chat GPT
and Dolly he's been a figure in Silicon
Valley for years as a founder and an
investor but now Altman is at the center
of one of the fastest developing
Technologies that's raising both
excitement and concern wsj reporter
Berber Jin spoke to Altman about open Ai
and how he's balancing business concerns
and Berber joins me now hey Berber
thanks for being here hey Zoe can you
give us a little background on Sam
Altman who was he before open AI he's a
very Silicon Valley type of figure he's
almost a bit of a celebrity
and it's because he ran this startup
accelerator called Y combinator which
essentially accepts mostly college
students who are applying to create
companies they want to create the next
Dropbox they want to create the next
Uber and then before that he dropped out
of Stanford to create a social
networking startup called looped which
wasn't very successful it actually sold
for close to the amount of money that
investors put into the company
come to co-found open AI
2014 2015.
that was a time when a lot of people in
Silicon Valley including Elon Musk were
growing very concerned about the sort of
dystopian potential of AI and I think
Sam shared in the concern of ai's misuse
he worked at an AI lab in college he had
always been fascinated by computers as a
kid and I think he's a bit different
from other startup Founders he cares a
lot about sort of Frontier technology
nuclear fusion human longevity AI sort
of fit into that bucket of really
advanced technology that he
wanted to develop and so in 2015 he
decided to co-found this non-profit
called open AI
primarily alongside Elon Musk when
openai started it was this non-profit
now it has a for-profit wing to it can
you tell us a little bit about that
shift and why it was made you know
according to the open AI co-founders
what they realized in 2017 two years
after the lab started was that the best
way to make progress in AI was through
large language models which is the
technology underpinning chat gbt it's
these Advanced AI algorithms that can
become smarter by reading billions of
pages of human text and then sort of
mimicking human responses
based off pattern recognition
to different questions that a human asks
them so that type of training requires a
lot of computational power because
you're sort of running the algorithm on
billions of pages of text on the
internet and so openly I realized that
they wouldn't be able to raise that much
money as a non-profit they wanted to be
able to attract investors who wanted to
make a return on their investment in
open Ai and so the only way to do that
was to create a for-profit how has that
decision to create a for-profit arm been
perceived by people inside and outside
of openai it was incredibly
controversial and Sam alienated a lot of
people that he worked closely with
because openai's mission was always to
develop artificial intelligence outside
the influence of shareholders
the two people who's really alienated
the first is Elon Musk he was a
co-founder in the company he didn't like
the decision to turn it into a
for-profit he wanted more control in
he was essentially rebuffed and in the
past few months after the release of
chat gbt he's been in really vocal on
Twitter and privately about the New Deal
that open air has done with Microsoft
the 10 billion dollar investment which
of course is enabled by the decision to
become a for-profit
and he's criticized the degree of
corporate influence that openai has come
under they are selling their models to
companies like Snapchat and instacart
their licensing their technology to
Microsoft so those decisions have come
under Fire he's also alienated a lot of
safety researchers who worked at open AI
over the years namely Dario amade who is
the lead safety researcher
he left in 2021 with several other open
AI researchers to found a rival AI lab
called anthropic
which focuses more on the safety side of
AI research what did Altman say about
the Microsoft deal in particular Sam
sort of frames it as something that he
almost had no choice
but to do again given the large
computational costs associated with
developing large language models he
emphasizes that it's not a typical
corporate partnership right openai has
the right to cancel Microsoft shares at
any time if they think the partnership
has gone astray or if it started to
develop dangerous Technologies or
if another organization developed
powerful Ai and openai wanted to assist
them
instead of competing with them
and he emphasizes as well that there are
profit caps to Microsoft's investment so
Microsoft can't make more better seven
times the total amount of money
they've invested that's still a very
large profit cap considering they
invested 13 billion but you know it is
unusual for an investor to have their
profits capped in that way what is his
take on the idea of having global
standards or a global governance to over
Cai so he was a bit vague about this
over time he wants the executive team at
openai to have less control over the
technology he wants to give everyday
citizens a say in the technology again
he wasn't very specific about it it's
clear he's thought about it and he wants
to engage different stakeholders along
the way he didn't go into specifics
about what that would look like but he's
been saying it for years I mean he said
it in 2016 so I guess we'll see so how
is open AI dealing with concerns about
the risks of this technology their
philosophy is that it's better to put
some of this technology into the world
and allow people to become familiar with
it play around with it and then also for
openai to gather feedback on the way in
which those releases can be further
refined to make it more aligned with
human values so what comes next for
openai and for Altman yeah so they just
released gpt4 which is the most powerful
language model that they've released
so the next step is gpt5 Sam is also
thinking a lot about that Global
governance aspect so I think we can
expect to see also some more like
concerted political efforts by openai to
try and shape policies around like
regulation at the government level so a
lot more to potentially watch with Sam
Altman that's wsj reporter berbergin
thanks for joining us Berber it's a
pleasure as always and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories head over to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]